the pride and sorrow of magical chess
Paul Morphy we're now going to take a
look at five of his most magical moments
make sure you do like this video now and
subscribe to the channel this is pure
energy pure joy that we're going to see
coming from his moves one of my favorite
players of all time
in this first example he's playing
against Henry Byrd international English
player Henry Byrd has just canceled now
this really epitomizes more fees style
and his genius vision rook takes F to I
mean just whoa out of the blue
funderbolt chest and this is amazing
because of the geometric shapes that are
created this rook is now taken and what
is more of these idea can you see it
well he's opened up the third-ranked
and now he can play Queen to a3 another
simply astounding move threatening
checkmate but if the Queen is taken
bishop takes a freak checkmate occurs so
the only defense is C free trying to
defend this and after Queen takes a two
we can see that morphe has this
brilliant attack one idea is a check and
then capture on B 2 which would be
checkmate and after b4 he gave a check
and now Queen's way for check and here
we see the second sacrifice we have to
break through White's defenses and
Bishop takes b4 allows the rook and
Queen to rampage against the naked white
King pawn takes Bishop rook takes the
rook and queen are rampaging against the
lone White King a beautiful idea one of
my all-time favorite ideas but it
doesn't stop there we have more magical
moments to look at from this legend of
chess morphe let's go over to the second
example now this next example has
something very poetic and artistic about
it chess can be an artistic pursuit it
can be a science it can be many things
but when morphe was playing it was more
or something glorious to behold now it's
a bit easy on the last one can you spot
it at home come on guys let's get a
little clock out do you know being black
to move what do you do
the move is Knight to g3 and this is
quite an astonishing move shades of the
golden coin game if you remember that
game of Frank Marshalls the Queen's are
interposed
and the problem is if white captures the
knight in any way black just simply
grabs the Queen and will win the game
and after the kind of obvious move Queen
Tate g6 it's now check mate the knight
slides in to e2 with an elegant finish
putting the cherry on the top of more
fees cake so a lovely final position and
let's move on to a nother magical moment
from one of more fees brilliant games
Morphy loved sacrificing he was in this
world of capitalism someone who liked to
give a little bit to his opponent but
only with proper backing so he could
exchange Queens but that's a bit boring
is it not what is the move well he now
plays Queen takes f3 and astonishing
sacrifice to tear apart the defense of
the white king and now after G takes
that free rook to g6 check the idea
behind the concept the King slips into
the corner and now another piece dives
in Bishop to h3 this attacks the rook
and when the rook moves we see the yo-yo
and the yoyo is where white cannot
escape the checks but black can sort of
sit back and just enjoy himself I could
even see Morphy now having his pipe
tobacco in the old days this was allowed
not good for your health nowadays and
just enjoying himself at this moment
bishop - g - bishop takes their free
check
King f1 Bishop to G to the yo-yo King to
g1 bishop to h3
the King comes back and now rather than
repeating the position which would lead
to a draw
he plays Bishop takes f2 taken away the
g1 square so Bishop to g2 is now gonna
be checkmate there's only one defensive
move Queen f1 but now White's has to
return his Queen and after the capture
on f1 Morphy came in with the rook and
he has a dominating position all of
black's pieces are massing around the
poor King on h1 the hungry bear gets his
mark and wins in some style a lovely
example there but there's still more to
come let's move on to number 4 morphe
had this sort of special superpower I'd
say on the board to shock his opponents
with moves that just came from nowhere
this is why I call him the magician
because he really did surprise this next
example is no different it's more feats
of play can you find the morphe concept
now he doesn't have that many pieces
attacking but with his next move rook to
e8 a sacrifice on an empty square it
allows the Queen to come to see a a
little distraction technique the King is
distracted away from the bishop white
flies in to capture that bishop we've
check the King comes forwards and now
the second blow Knight takes d5 check
now this is a brilliant move because
Queen to e6 check is only a check and
black can defend and carry on with King
to d8 but after another piece comes into
the action
now the problem black has if he takes to
the Queen he loses his Queen he can
resign if he takes with the pawn he
loses his Queen probably better than
what he played though he went King to d6
in the olden days they liked to resign
in style but he good show old boy if I'm
gonna lose I'm gonna
lose with checkmate something which I
would love to see a bit more of nowadays
and can you see it Queen to c7 and they
shook hands and they enjoyed a lovely a
lovely Kodiak as well I believe after
the game lovely stuff
lovely lovely day bravo Bravo
well we've seen this concept before it's
white to play and win and in this game
white is striking across two very
impressive diagonals the rook comes into
e8 a simply lovely maneuver to play and
this takes away the blacks queen defense
of the rook on f6 it has to be taken and
what is White's idea Queen takes f6 and
this is simply astonishing because if
pawn takes the bishop comes in and look
at those laser beams they're attacking
the King and there's nothing that black
King can do if I ever got a checkmate
like this I would just sit there with a
very smug look at my face and think yeah
you know look at that I might even just
have the board in front me for at least
a week go around you know even if I'm
travelling public transport on the train
I'll get a random person and I'll just
be like yeah look at that position look
at that I'd stick the pieces to the
board you know on the bus I'll be like
yeah yeah look at that man look at that
that's what I created I did that oh god
the bishop was mad yeah whoa so
something to be proud of
black try to defend were Queen to e7
defending this pawn but now comes
another astonishing concept Queen takes
g7 and this gets rid of that pawn and
after this slow and delicate move f6
black cannot stop the end the end is
nigh the pointers if black tries moving
the Queen anywhere the pawn moves on
releasing the bishop if that is blot the
porns marches on a brave soldier and
delivers checkmate
so a lovely concept black desperate
kanji - but is clear to see he's losing
here there's still no adequate defense
to f7 oh I just wish I could play chess
like that haha so beautiful five
examples do like this video subscribe to
the channel now please we're gonna have
more examples coming up in the future
but Morphy what a joy to behold
happily oh look at these videos
[Music]